mais l'élection sénatoriale ne peut pas
nous être favorable c est
structurellement impossible puisque je
le rappelle les grands électeurs ont été
choisi suite aux élections municipales
départementales régionales de 2010 et
2014 et 2015 la république en marche
n'existait pas donc évidemment qu'elles
puissent elles peuvent pas nous est
favorable
par contre nous allons nous anticipons
quand même une hausse du nombre de
députés on a eu deux sénateurs pardon on
a une trentaine de sénateurs à l'heure
actuelle on a un objectif 48,50 qui est
un objectif ambitieux donc nous nous
battons au quotidien
l'ensemble des élus l'ensemble des
militants la république en marche pour
aller convaincre les grands électeurs un
par un pour faire le plus de sénateurs
si nous n'avons pas la majorité des
trois cinquièmes comme vous venez de
parler le président de la république a
été très clair dans son discours à
versailles
donc il passera probablement aussi
besoin s'il ya un blocage même peut-être
par référendum
vous le souhaiterez a bien moi je
souhaite qu'ils aient pas de blocage et
qu'on ait une majorité donc je me bats
pour avoir une majorité dimanche